anyone that knows me knows I'm a Gulf
obsessed I moved to the states where
they go and I couldn't I you know I got
the DirecTV down there to cable and I
couldn't I don't know I don't I still
don't know to this day any of the
channels apart from the god channel 218
except that you got channeling then but
just under what that's how I really need
to do exactly that's it that's it
congratulations on this latest song I
mean it is just blowing up everywhere
and everybody loves it what was it about
the song that made you feel like this
was the one that was going to come out
first
uh I don't really know I got I let
everyone else choose it for me because
they're they're they're people who
listened to the radio a lot and you know
can picture it on the radio so I know I
was in two minds of between that and
another song and and then I just met me
when she was for Apple but I just wanted
to show show people that I was up for
doing something different you know I
brought my first song is effectively me
a guitar
and some nice strings and I wanted to
kind of show that a different flavor to
the album and yeah had you always
thought that you wanted to go solo
because I mean that's a big decision you
know and it was it something that you
always knew you were going to do or you
just or directly happen no not
necessarily no I just happened I know
was I didn't really plan on doing much
last year at all and then I went
backpacking when I came back from edge I
just started writing again like I would
normally I just write in the house get
over to my mates to do and then just
write with him and I wrote this town of
the first day which is a golf that would
start and then can I just said to my
management's maybe we should do
something and we weren't talking to
labels after I'd played a few songs and
yeah I got signed there we are what's
the biggest difference for you besides
the obvious about being in a group and
being out there in front of everyone
doing interviews and all of that and
even on stage what's the biggest
difference for you I guess it's the
dwarfs obvious one really is that
there's there's a lot less people
usually if we're into Bennett video
there's a big coach here
yeah sort of people I guess just the day
today is the biggest difference like
waking up in them on and you know
everyone getting ready
hustle and bustle of
the circus huh yeah that we brought with
us yeah I guess that's the biggest
difference yeah and then I guess do a
guy I'd probably notice it more on tour
yeah
you know when I do a tour where I'm you
know singing for an hour and a half me
trying to control the room yeah you know
it's a new it's a new thing for me as
well so yeah I guess I know is it more
than are you are you more nervous than
you were when you're up on stage before
is it a different feeling up there
frankly it was at the start it was
strange when I started yeah yeah it did
feel a little bit weird but I do feel
most comfortable in life where they have
a guitar hand that's my go-to thing so
when I'm up there at being onstage just
in my head it just works I don't know I
don't know what it is um probably sounds
quite like an like an ignorant thing to
say but I just said I don't know what
what is I just feel apart from like live
TV live TV and live radio stuff is you
wanna get one goal in it right so don't
let stop I get I do get really nervous
to the points like couple years ago I
used to like feel like really like
butterflies yeah proper like feeling
sick type thing yeah
that was because you were about yourself
yeah well actually even when do even
with the lads just like just get really
nervous for some reason before I've been
like doing laps of the room trying to
count myself down I just got better at
it over I guess
stop me first rodeos pretty unique
experience what the things that you've
gone through so it's just it's pretty
pretty amazing who do you go to to sort
of bounce your music off of or you know
who do you go to who's your person is
someone in the the former band or is it
friend family yeah well I mean something
my cousin lived together and like I'll
come home from the shoot he's got like a
really good the area basically lives on
Spotify and I like I'd play him
something and say I'll play him
something and then he'd give me an ideas
like we compare it to another song that
I've written of a similar style I then
well yeah I don't know I just always
playing it around like we made like I'll
write something I'll play it around the
house quietly and then people who can go
with that you know
I could try Ellen like a very organic
kind of opinion yeah yeah I prefer to
get a real opinion on it and people
blown smoke well don't you find that
happens a lot more these days
no no I don't let it happen you don't
let it happen I don't I don't give
people the opportunity to to be like
that around me mm-hmm this single has
gone and like I said it's been saying it
for like three days you know what was
the reaction been from your friends and
family I mean everybody knows your town
said everyone knows you're good at what
you do with the songs pretty amazing
yeah I just I'm really happy that I
could go back to what I grew up on that
style of music yeah put my own twist on
it and and release what is effectively
an 80 song these days with whether for
the fact it is an 80 song and release it
knows I'm kind of happy I can do that
yeah and then just for friends or family
or delay because like made my dad you
know my mom did we're big fans of this
kind of stuff so they think it's just
great thank you
everyone's happy I love it do you have
any Canadian musicians that love it like
I know your friends is Michael Buble and
a few other people have they heard the
song and there's no I I'm sure yeah I
haven't like actually got a really nice
message of a voice message of Michael
Dillard a semi really nice greatest man
I want to grow up to be Michael do the
two of your kind of cut from the same
cloth I've interviewed twice now and I
never you'd Michael a couple of times
and you're like sweet kind people okay
thank you good people
Thanks yeah thanks ed oh yeah he's
correct Kay and then I actually played a
couple of I was over my house last week
Sean came over Shawn Mendes and we were
had a couple of beers and we were
jamming with little Ben and I played a
couple of songs to him
yeah he'd seem to like them right so the
album is coming out I'm thinking October
November time yeah there's a lot of
stuff going on at the minute prom always
around the world okay performing on
things down in Australia and and it's
got a crazy two minutes or when I get
time to stop that and when that stops
and then release it yes I'm really
looking forward to it and I again like
you know I did release a Sunglass
September and release another one now
and it's been like it's kind of a year
or campaign clearly but like the way I
said it to everyone I just kind of want
to do everything at my own pace
everything at my own pace and and and
not rush everything out because then
today I am 23 so I've got no say any
collaborations on this album my fingers
crossed over I'm looking to get a couple
I have a couple of songs that could
potentially be something like that and
fingers crossed they can get to play
some stuff to people and see what
happens but yeah I did a whole idea of
collaboration is you know it's great
because like I don't think there's a lot
of it going on in our world anyway and
it's matched not as much as it should be
so now would you stay away from doing
collaboration with the other guys from
one direction or cat rule anything out
really good yeah yeah I suppose right
now it's baby it would be a bit weird
but uh yeah never ruler I'd never rule
anything else guys nice